- [Narrator] If you are a
female and have certain problems
with your reproductive organs,
your doctor may recommend
a robotic hysterectomy
to remove your uterus.
Your reproductive organs
include your vagina,
cervix,
uterus,
fallopian tubes,
and ovaries.
You may need a robotic
hysterectomy if you have
one of the following
diseases or conditions,
heavy or constant uterine bleeding,
anemia and pelvic pain,
cancer in your uterus,
cervix, or ovaries,
noncancerous fibroid
tumors in your uterus,
or slipping and sagging of your uterus
into your vagina due to weak
or injured pelvic muscles
and uterine ligaments.
Before your procedure,
and intravenous line,
or IV, will be started.
You may be given
antibiotics through the IV
to decrease your chance of infection.
You'll be given general anesthesia.
A breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and down your throat
to help you breathe during the operation.
Your surgeon will make a small incision
near your belly button and insert
a plastic tube called a port.
Carbon dioxide gas will be pumped
into your abdomen through this port.
The gas will inflate your abdomen,
giving your surgeon more room to see
and move the surgical tools.
After your abdomen is inflated,
a high-definition camera will
be inserted into this port.
Your surgeon will make
additional port incisions
for robotic instruments
as well as instruments
used by patient side assistance.
An assistant will insert all of the
robotic tools through these ports.
Unlike standard laparoscopic instruments,
these tools can rotate 360 degrees
and have more flexibility
than the human wrist.
Seated at a special console,
your surgeon will operate the robotic arms
and the camera with joystick-like
controls and foot pedals.
A computer will translate
the exact movements
of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools.
At the same time,
a high-definition vision
system will provide
a magnified three dimensional
stereoscopic view of the surgical area.
Depending on your condition,
you may have a partial hysterectomy
in which your surgeon
will remove your uterus,
but leave your cervix, fallopian tubes,
and ovaries in place.
If you have a total hysterectomy,
your surgeon will remove
your cervix along with your uterus.
If you have a radical
hysterectomy, your surgeon may also
remove your fallopian tubes, ovaries,
the upper part of your vagina,
as well as nearby tissue such
as your pelvic lymph nodes.
At the end of your procedure,
the tiny incisions will
be closed with stitches,
staples, surgical glue,
or closure tape dressings.
After your procedure, your
breathing tube will be removed
and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring.
You will be given pain
medication as needed.
You may continue to receive
antibiotics through your IV.
You may be released from
the hospital the same day
or within one day after the procedure.